[Music]
straight ahead prime daily
a grand jury makes a decision in the
police killing of briana taylor
a breakdown of an explosive announcement
also
that was his plea so why is this
defendant trying to change his story
after prosecutors say
he recorded a murder it is horribly
graphic
it's absolutely monstrous and how police
say they solved a 46-year-old murder
on law and crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin a kentucky
grand jury recommending no
charges directly against the police
related to the shooting death
of brianna taylor that announcement
concluding a grand jury probe into the
shooting
which happened as plainclothes officers
busted down taylor's door in an attempt
to execute a no knock warrant taylor's
boyfriend thought the officers
were intruders gunfire erupted with the
police firing most of the rounds
two of the officers involved miles
cosgrove and john mattingly
are off the hook but the grand jury
decided officer brett hinkinson
should be charged with three counts of
first-degree wanton
endangerment that's for firing shots
into
neighbors apartments hankinson has
already been fired from the force
the grand jury voted to return an
indictment
against detective hankinson for three
counts
of wanton endangerment for wantonly
placing
the three individuals in apartment three
in danger
of serious physical injury or death
the charge one endangerment in the first
degree is a class
d felony and if found guilty the accused
conserve up to five years
for each count our investigation showed
and the grand jury agreed that mattingly
and cosgrove
were justified in the return of deadly
fire
after having been fired upon by kenneth
walker
let me state that again according to
kentucky law
the use of force by mattingly and
cosgrove was justified
to protect themselves this justification
bars us from pursuing criminal charges
in ms brianna taylor's death
the attorney general's office says
taylor was shot six times not five as
her death certificate listed
and the fbi crime lab concluded the
fatal shot was fired by detective
cosgrove
there was no video or body camera
footage of the officer's attempted
execution of a search warrant at miss
taylor's
residence video footage begins at the
point that area patrol officers
arrive at the location therefore
the sequence of events from march 13th
had to be pieced together
through ballistics evidence 911
calls police radio traffic and
interviews we utilized information
from the kentucky state police local
medical examiners
as well as working with the fbi crime
lab
in quantico to secure a trajectory
analysis
and ballistics report our team conducted
interviews in this case and spent
thousands of
hours examining all of the available
evidence
we concluded our last interview in this
case
this past friday and began our grand
jury presentation
on monday okay brian let's talk about
the charge that was filed here what does
the one officer face and why do you
think the other two
ultimately were not charged
so i don't think the other two were char
group based on the fact of how this
all went down i think the very fact that
kenneth walker is accused of shooting
first in self-defense as was eventually
found out because
he was treated like everyone else he was
arrested
he was confined and then they found the
truth the officers they get the benefit
of the doubt that kenneth walker and
many people don't get
but they ultimately came to the same
decision that those three were acting
responsibly in terms of the law and
self-defense
however the third officer hankinson or
third officer sorry
he acted in a way that was wanting and
and disregarded
human life and that's why he's getting
that d-class felony
okay so terry the attorney general said
this grand jury started digging into
things
on a monday morning and there was a
decision by noon
on wednesday is that too short of a time
in your opinion to dig into a case of
this magnitude
absolutely particularly since they had
so much time this crime occurred on
march 13th
and the average length of a grand jury
especially is on the state
level it varies from a week or two weeks
or you know a month or more
and here to say that it occurred in a
couple of days
i don't think that the attorney
general's office made sure that
all of the evidence got before the grand
jury it seems as though
only evidence about this one particular
charge
for first degree wanton endangerment was
presented
and brian we're hearing of discrepancies
here why no body camera footage
why are we hearing neighbors telling
reporters that they heard nothing from
the police
but then the authorities are saying no
no there's evidence that some neighbors
did hear
the police announce their presence
yeah so the evidence is coming out as
the prosecutor wanted to
because the prosecutor has the sole
discretion as to how they prosecute
cases
both at trial and in the grand jury so
they're presenting information
in one way and that's how it came out no
murder no manslaughter
only the charge that they can prove the
most beyond a reasonable doubt
and not the way that it operates for so
many other defendants in this country
good points brian and terry
the widow of nba player kobe bryant has
filed a civil lawsuit against the los
angeles county sheriff's department
claiming deputies there took
unauthorized photos of the helicopter
crash which claimed the life
of the basketball star the private
charter craft went down in heavy fog
about 30 miles northwest of los
angeles back in january bryant his
daughter the pilot
and all six others aboard that aircraft
died terry austin explains the lawsuit
the complaint alleges civil rights
violations the intentional infliction of
emotional distress
and invasion of privacy these images
from the scene of the crash were
recorded by the national transportation
safety board and were authorized for
release
the lawsuit says the county sheriff
promised widow vanessa bryant
that the site was secure however eight
deputies at the scene
used their cell phones to take pictures
of the dead victims
for their personal gratification the
images were shared within the department
and even at a bar the lawsuit claims a
bartender was so appalled
that he filed a complaint the lawsuit
says the sheriff told the deputies that
if they deleted the so-called illicit
photos
they would not be disciplined the
lawsuit characterizes the official
response
as a cover-up mrs bryant
feels ill at the thought of strangers
gawking at
images of her deceased husband and child
and she lives in fear
that she or her children will one day
confront horrific
images of their loved ones online
thanks a lot terry and now to brian
buckmeyer for some perspective on this
yeah erin i spoke earlier today with
retired swat team member lisa lockwood
she says the crime scene techs are the
ones who are supposed to be taking
photos in the field not officers unless
there's an emergency which requires an
officer to record the scene before the
tech arrives
now she criticized the officers for
taking pictures in the case
but said discipline would be unlikely
unless a pattern of bad conduct emerges
over time
actually take out your camera and take
personal photos of a crime scene
in a place where it didn't warrant that
warrant that
is conduct unbecoming and i believe
vanessa has every right to do what she's
doing because
once it was leaked and it was found out
and reported she contacted lapd and
basically said why is this happening
what kind of discipline is being done
and the response that she got was i they
were told to delete the photos
i mean it was so dismissive and so
disrespectful
to this woman who lost her husband and
her child the amount of mental anguish
knowing that these exist and they're out
there in the public is so
grotesque and disheartening the police
officers could have
sold those images and this could have
gotten a lot worse so is it cause for
firing
probably not and it would be based on
priors with the police officers
now lockwood says that while officers do
have the legal right
to show pictures that the public has
already seen of a crime scene
they should not be photographing what
the public is blocked from actually
seeing
so brian what's disturbing here in my
opinion is that vanessa bryant asked for
a perimeter and exclusionary zone around
this scene
officers said they would grant it they
just didn't police it against themselves
exactly it's another situation where we
are asking for
our men and women and people in blue to
protect us not just from
violence but also our privacy and when
we're thinking that others are going to
harm that
it's actually the officers who are
harming the individual instead and
that's
that's sad and tragic in so many ways
terry the sheriff basically said this is
a problem in
every law enforcement department my
question though is this a strong or a
weak case
for the widow of kobe bryant i think
vanessa has
a very good case because she's claiming
invasion of privacy
and i think clearly this was an invasion
of privacy she's also claiming
intentional infliction
of emotional distress and the distress
that she must have suffered
knowing that these pictures were out in
the public domain is
very stressful so i think she has a good
cause of action here and
hopefully she will prevail
a sad story all the way around and still
ahead on law and crime daily a new
lawsuit against carol baskin
the star of the docu-series tiger king
but first a defendant tells a judge he
was
guilty after spreading photos of the
murder
he said he committed on the internet so
how can he suddenly change his mind
a young upstate new york man is trying
to walk back his guilty plea after he
originally
admitted that he killed his 17-year-old
girlfriend and then posted pictures
of the victim's body on the internet
victim bianca devins died in july 2019
after attending a concert in new york
city with brandon clark
prosecutors even say clark made a video
of himself
killing bianca devins clark admitted to
the killing in open court
but now he claims his original attorney
coerced him
into admitting to the charges these were
some of the defendant's own words at a
plea hearing this past february
on the date of july 14 2019
while you were here in the city of utica
in the county of omega
with intent to cause the death of
beyonce who did cause the death
of the young condemned is that
interesting
mr clark yes your honor i know that
sorry's not enough
i know that won't take back what i did
every day since july 14th i've thought
about it
i thought about the terrible things i
did that day things that the word
tragedy
really isn't enough for i thought about
the lives i've torn apart
with my actions and i've thought about
bianca
and now she didn't deserve what happened
to her
at the time of that plea hearing the
defendant's guilty admission came as a
relief to the victim's grandfather
it would be a very hard thing to go
through that trial
and we're grateful that he has
chosen to plead guilty statement to me
that stood out
was that he said bianca did not deserve
this
and that's right she did nothing to
deserve this
so uh in that way he's taking
full responsibility that these were his
actions
done by him caused by him
missing a blocker every day
god bless you mean pat we all love you
so very much
the local prosecutor added a charge of
promoting contraband at the county jail
which according to the prosecutor
resulted in a discussion with the
defense about
a plea for second-degree murder in
return for dropping that lesser
contraband charge here is how the
prosecutor summed up the matter
this past winter so when we brought that
charge his attorney began talking to us
that maybe he felt
that if we would satisfy the promoting
charge
with the plea to murder in the second
degree
that that would be something that
brandon wanted to do as you've probably
heard he videotaped the homicide
all i can say is i'm very grateful that
12 jurors from our community don't have
to see what
brandon did to bianca this case will
always stay with me
not a lot of folks have actually seen
the video the content
because it is horribly graphic
it's absolutely monstrous and it's
something i'll never forget this
will be one of those cases that will
stay with me for the rest of my life
okay brian i don't want to misconstrue
what the prosecutor said because it
sounds like
she was considering adding charges
around the time the defendant was
considering pleading guilty
and the defense turned around and said
okay well you know there's a plea in the
works here so why don't you lay off the
lesser charge and we'll just go forward
with the plea
on the big charge but does that sound
right to you or does something seem a
mess
it seems pretty commonplace at first
when i heard this i thought well maybe
they're trying to supersede
with stronger charges and that might be
a reason to motivate or manipulate as
the defense the defendant might think
to take this plea but he shouldn't
really be concerned of those lesser
charges when he's looking at that murder
charge
the only thing i can think might happen
here this might be an issue of form
rather than substance
and the defendant is saying that he did
not knowingly and voluntarily take this
plea
even though he admitted to it maybe he's
saying his course by his defense
attorney
it's an interesting procedure a case
terry how hard is it to actually claw
back a guilty plea
well it's going to be hard in this case
because he was so
forthright in the plea he stated so much
during that hearing he said he was sorry
he said she did not deserve to die like
this and so
i think that it's going to be difficult
to claw it back but you know what at the
end of the day
they may just do it just because the
judge in the court wants to make sure
that his due process rights are not
violated
that's a great point terry but again
good judges are very
careful about getting solid pleas on the
record to avoid this situation so we
will certainly watch this case
and later on in the broadcast a
boyfriend attacked in an alley a
girlfriend later found dead who did it
police say they have finally found their
man after 46 years
plus federal authorities explained why
they think r kelly should remain in jail
even after he was attacked behind bars
that's when long prime daily continues
time now to check in on other high
profile cases we are tracking here at
law on crime daily
federal prosecutors say they that
embattled r b singer r kelly does not
need to be let out of jail before his
upcoming sex crimes cases go to trial
kelly seen here at a previous hearing
argued to be released because he was
attacked at chicago's metropolitan
corrections center
authorities say they moved kelly's
attacker to a different facility in
michigan
and therefore the threat no longer
exists against kelly
the family of don lewis has filed an
amended legal document against tiger
king star carol baskin
lewis's family and lewis's assistant are
trying to dig further into suggestions
that baskin had something to do with her
former husband's mysterious
disappearance
and presumed death the amended bill of
discovery uses baskin's odin words
against her and
adds a claim for defamation don lewis's
personal assistant ann mcqueen claims
baskin has been lying about her
since as far back as 1997. and now to
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross for check on what he's working on
this week
thanks aaron coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
the president the playmate and the
crucifix
new details about a gift that karen
mcdougall former playmate says
donald trump gave her in the middle of
what she says was a 10-month affair
donald had given me those items
personally he thought they were amazing
gifts
and he thought about me mr trump has
denied any affair and his office denies
there was any gift we'll have all the
details coming up on brian ross
investigates
on the law and crime trial network back
to you erin
and when we come back here on law and
crime daily an arrest in a 46 year old
cold case evidence detectives are saying
led to the break
when we return
[Music]
texas authorities say a family there now
has answers to a 46-year-old question
17-year-old carla walker attended a
valentine's day dance with her boyfriend
in 1974.
an attacker pulled her out of a car in a
bowling alley parking lot
the boyfriend was attacked and walker
was kidnapped three days later
walker's body turned up in a culvert
using genealogy techniques similar to
those utilized in the case of
california's golden state killer
investigators recently retested the
victim's bra and got a hit for a
suspect's dna
basically when we had done testing
before sometimes when you do testing you
don't always get a full profile
this time when we retested we got a full
profile and that allowed us
more options available to seek out who
this could be
and to be clear you mentioned retest
that it re-tested for bra you got the
full profile correct and why did you get
the full profile like how did how does
that happen
just new technology uh different people
trying different methods
um dna has been around basically since
the mid 80s
but there are continual advances in how
they
attempt to find that dna and then also
how they extract that dna
so it was these newer processes that
enabled us to get a
full profile as opposed to a partial
from food
walker's parents have since passed away
but her brother says the family is
thankful for the arrest
the word that came across my brain was
finally
finally after 46 years
five months
three days we have a name of face
and we're moving toward complete
resolution
i would like to sit here and tell you no
i never gave up hope
um but there were times there were
really dark times and
watching the pain my mom
went through you know i can tell you
this whole case being resolved is a
thank you guy so terry the authorities
make this sound so definitive and what's
disturbing about this
is that there's no link between the
suspect and
the victim right well you know a random
crime is
generally more difficult to prove
because you don't have a motive
to link you back to the defendant so
that is why genealogy is so important
with these cold cases because
they can take the dna from the defendant
and
they did hear they took it from his
trash can and then they can match it to
the
dna that was found on the victim and
that's exactly what they did here so
fortunately we now have techniques that
can solve these cold cases it's like the
golden state killer as you said
and it also reminds me a lot of the
jerry burns case that we recently
reported about
in iowa exactly so brian the question
though is is this really case closed
we've got to wait for a plea we could
have a trial here there could be a
defense
i still think that we're pretty far from
thinking about this being a case closed
there are still a lot of questions that
are unanswered
and simply having dna doesn't prove
guilt or innocence either way
they're going to be a lot more
supporting facts that mean one way or
the other
and it's up to the lawyers and the
evidence to figure out where this leads
for the jury
keep an open mind because you never know
what the plea might be there may be a
good defense here we'll have to see
thank you so much for the analysis brian
and terry and thank you for joining us
as we discuss justice in america
in our police departments and in our
courts right here on law and crime daily
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
[Music]
today
[Music]
you